BE LISTENING.
>> WE DO HAVE CNPOCOVERING THE O
ANGLE FROMO LVIV T
IS LE ON THE GROUND INKH NOW.
>> Reporter: BRIANNA JOH
THE ATTACK ON THE MILITARY
INSTALLATIO FAR
THE ATTACKS HAVE B
INSTALLATIONS STARTED A
OFOREN HERE
IN KHARKIV.
YOU RECALL JUS
BORD WHICH IS ONLY 25 MILES A VL
FORCE HAS BEENUI
AROUND BELE.THEY WERE ABLE TARU
DIRECTION SOUTH TOWARDS A
MILITARYLLATION.
K ATHEN OF ATTACKS AE
UN THE AIM OF THE PU
ADMINISTRATION AT THIS SN
THE CONFLICT IS TO ATTAC
DEONVE BEE AND AIR
INSTALLATIONAND COMMUNICATIONSAR
THE MAYOOF KHARKIV HAS ASKEDOPL
BEING OPENED UE AS O R IF THE
CONFLICT COMES CS
CIAT LEAST 1.5 MILLION
PEOPLE.
THREIMATESABLY PUT TOUND 2
SECONT THE
IT'S A SIGNIFICA
GAME AN IS.
BELARUS SOUTH ?OM E  THAT THREAE
THREATENING KHARKIV BY K
HE'S SNG PSK AND DONETSK.EEU H
ALLING THEM NAZI
THEY HAD A LIST OF PEOPL
REKILLCA
JAIL A O PROGRAMO ATTACK THE ST
POLITICAL STRUCTURES STILL
RUNNING THE COUNTRY.
>> I WANT TO GIVE PEOPLE SHERE
HE WERE TALKINT
WHERE WE SAW S PLIES BEING AMAS.
YOU SAID FREDERICKARTILLERY.
IT IS
REGION.M,NYACD YORDINIV AT  PO.
BEEN ABLE
WE A LETTING DOWN.
S  FIRST WAVE
OF TIT HE.
ERABOUT THE NT OF GROUND TROOPS.
THIS HAVE BEEN REPORTS IN  THE N
APARG STRUCK
M JUST ABOUT 150 YAR UTO
N
HOSPITAL WCHXT TF MEDICA I
RTAINLY NOT A RUSH OF PEOPLE  A
THE POPULAONS SOSTREETS.
STAYED IN.ERHN ABRIANNA, CLAIMSH
KNT ARCL ARE
RUSSIAN TANKS ONG ROAD
SURROUNDING AS VER ROAD
THERE ARE SOCIAL MEDIA POSTS O
THAT WHICH WE G.E UKRAINIAN MILM
YESTERDAY ON WHAT WAS THE FRONT
LINEEYE MBER OF AIRCRAFT
NU OF RUSSIANS KILLE
E THES
DEFENS ONLVET CASUALTY
FREQUENTLY THERUTH.
KHARKIV,D SAM,YO TAL ABOUTOT.PL.
ST SP US
T'THIS IS IN WESTERN UKRAINE.
BRING IN MICHAELS.
I UNDERSTA HAVEN A
RAor, THERE HAVE.
MULTIPLE TIMES.
JOHN, JUST TO GI YOU A SENSE,
THIS IS  THE THE
TO POLAND
HERE.
THISS E EML
FLEDU LIKE.
THEY MOVED THEIRTUFFF
KYIV ANDE HEREO IV.
THE U.S. STAFF FOR THEIR OWN
TYOS
COME BACK TOK O
E THE  ARAID
WE THEM EIGHT DIFFERENT
TIER THE NEXUPLE OF HOURS, THAT.
MEANWH SEEN THINGS
LIKE RUNS ON THE ATMHE.
ES I YOU'RE SEEING
THERE, G SPLE
TRYING TS UP THEIR CARS, GETUEL.
ALSO AT AT
WE'VE O EARLIER  SOME
PEOPLE AIR RAID SHELTER
NGTO T
LOCAL TELEVI HME ON
IT WASKABLE TO STAY PO IT'.
INCTO STAY CALM, F THE AIR RAIDI
WHICH CLEARLAIY
S
ATION.
YOU'VE GOT A SENSE HERE, JOHN,
PERHAPS ESOU LE OFS ANTICIPATIOS
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN GOINGBO
THY LIVES BEING VERY
CALM BUT NRNALXIETY.
LE THOUGHTCOME AND YET
ARE,>> AGAIN, TOIVE OPSE
AS H, THE FAR WEST OF THE
Y AND IF THERE AREIRID SIR A
E , THOPHE CONCE  LGE 4LE. ELEC
BASIC SERVICES.
ANY SIGNS OF DISRUPTION TO ANY
FE,  COURSE. THAT S BEEN A
THAT'S SOMNG R
THEY COULD TY F THEYANTO, EITHER
HITTI INSTALLATIOBERFARE OR WH.
THEY COULD SHUT DOWN ELECTR
ELECTRICITY.
OULD CAUSE A LOT OF PANIC NC
OF WATERT GE
WER.
IN A REAL
CRISIS.
PENED YET.
WE H H
THE OTG YOU MENTIO
THE PROXIMITY MUCH WT OUT,
I SPOKE TOEONOREE COUNCIL ONY .T
DES POTENTIALLY
COD  TA MASSIV
CRISIS.D HAVE 2 PEOPL
FLEEING TO
COUNTRIES.
WE S THE TRAFFICS EARLIE
FROM KYIV HEADG
CAPITOL.
THER.
SO WE'RE EXPECTING A LOT O COMI.
>> THIS IS THE BORDER WITH
U.IN
POLAND TO DEAL WITH THE
POTENTFO
SIAT
MICHAEL LL UNLESS LVIVKEEP US P
>>> LESIS ON
THE SITU RETIRED
COLONEL  LEIGHTON, CNN
PENT G THE
WHAT IS YOUR ASSESSMENT HE
SITUATIO
BAD SITTIOR THE
IANS.
WHEN YOUOO T
TAKE A LOOK  MAP AEEKYIV HERE,O
ONE OF THE MAJOR TARTSE
FORT BT
THEY'RE GOING TO D COME DOWNLAS.
O  THROUGHE SAM
KILEY WAS WHAT ELSIS O IS
WE'VE HEARD EXPLOSIONS IN ODESSA
T E
EXOSCU
S THATRE'S PROBABLIL E
INROM THE BLACK SESOITHIS WHAT
AND HOW MU M TS THAN ERE?
THEM TO GO.INK THAT WHE--HE
INCREMENTAT T
P IN THE
WEST WAS NOT THE WAYUT WAS.
SO I EXPECT THEM TOOK AT T VARIS
AREAS THAT THEY ACTUALLY SET OFF
DETONATIONREHING THROUGHOUT
E  SHOWS
THERE WER